I assume that most Boston slang is we
mean towards somebody else that's what
I'm a sir a bubbler what about how do
you think that means
like the pub let's go above where let's
get bubble bubblee tonight it's when you
fight it's gotta be a device with which
you can smoke we did a guy with a lisp
just like bubbling around I thought this
was just Rhode Island in Wisconsin but
it's a drinking fountain both words of
drinking fun barrel um this is like a
big handled alcohol barrel means a lot
of things like you could have a barrel
of anything like a Boston sport fans
like huge beer gut either just having
fun and they had they had a barrel it
had a barrel last night yeah we had a
barrel of fun dot dot dot dot dot that
does that stop it's a matter
oh it's an old person it's the
Department of Transportation oh you see
that dot over there it is we keep like
that dot over there though I think a
dots like just like an absent-minded
friend like ah Karen she's such a dot
don't dogs yeah it's I think it's a
bootie reference I immediately want to
say sneakers there's my shoes yeah shoes
damn that girl's got dog in her trunk
the abbreviation for Dunkin Donuts which
is like church out there I mean yeah
it's just like a staple whiffle let's
look that says I saw you from Harry
Potter Red Sox play baseball the Yankees
played Wilfred it's like a play on on a
waffle
they're like cue you know it's not walk
what's a Whipple go on grab that guy I'm
gonna go grab my Whipple really teach
him a lesson
exactly Whipple totally it's gotta be a
bad reason all haircut
I think we should get whistles we should
get Whipple's what are you doing
tomorrow people from California get
whiffle's for the first